the gyro can experience they do however
test more than California so they're
more accurate in terms of their numbers
there's more testing being done in New
York City I think by three fold than
California it's crazy man this is a
whole new time and I really hope it's a
wake up call for us it is a wake up call
this is Doug listen as jokey as this may
sound or whatever I've always had a
faith my faith got me to where I am
faith in what a higher power let's call
it a higher power I always had a faith
in a higher power and if anybody knows
about karma is me I'm the [ __ ] poster
boy for karma I know all about it for me
this is like a power letting us know
like it's a reset button take a look
around you guys have gotten caught up in
selfies yeah like who's gotten caught up
in selfies you know you go see a [ __ ]
concert it's two hundred and fifty
dollars and sixty dollars to park you
know you go to a movie theater you walk
out an American family can't go to a
sporting event no more the normal
American family cannot go to a sporting
event no more without a lot of control
Joe we can't move in apartments no more
1500 for a studio
we just got greedy man the Greed's been
too much you know I gotta feel bad for
Disney losing six million suck my deck
you were charging 140 a day [ __ ]
140 a day I think that's the least of
our problem no I think the big problem
is people think this is all this life
the way we're living is gonna be
permanent no no no it's changing for a
reason yeah it's changing for we were
getting [ __ ] greedy well there's
definitely that and we were getting a
little overzealous but we're soft we're
soft that's the big one and especially
we're soft right here because we don't
have to deal with weather right here we
don't have to deal with nothing you go
outside every day you can sleep outside
it'd be alive it's a great place to be
homeless
I need a sleeping bag get under an
overpass if it does rain it only rains
ten days a year you'll be fine you know
this is this is a great place because of
that but because of that also we're not
humbled enough you know the places where
people get humble to the places where
people have to deal with direct nature
snowy places real cold places like if
you go to any place that's near an ocean
that's a little slap in the face like
wake up [ __ ] take a look at that you
ain't [ __ ] mountains are another one
same thing like you could die up there
stupid there's bears up there there's
mountain lions up there they're [ __ ]
killing deer with their face you don't
think they'll [ __ ] you up to go go hike
go hiking get lost hippie you know like
it's a wake up call those places and I
think this is a wake-up call for the
whole country the whole world is a
wake-up call we're vulnerable and it's
also a wake-up call I can't say it
enough people take care of your health
please it is a one defense for this that
seems to be agreed upon by almost
everyone is that if you have a strong
immune system you have a better chance
to get through any sickness and you can
do something to strengthen your immune
system your immune system is something
you can work on you know you can work on
it by cleaning up your diet you can work
on it with regular exercise you can work
on it with regular sleep all those
things have a real big impact on the
immune system also vitamin supplement
with vitamins eat a healthy diet get
some exercise and if you can get in a
[ __ ] sauna every day tremendous for
your body producing heat shock proteins
or your body reducing inflammation
alleviating stress it's great for your
cardiovascular system it's just great
for you there's a bunch of different
things you can do you can you can use
this it's like okay I'm alive now
there's a wake-up call I'm so glad this
didn't happen to me I didn't get wrecked
by this I'm gonna get my life in order
and it can be done it's something that
everyone can do and this is the time to
do it this is a good time to do it if
you're surviving and you're getting
through this this is a good time to get
your health in line what you don't know
a lot of people don't know about me is I
was a sickly kid really we never ever I
never believed from the age of 4 to 6
because of my dad died
my mind going some wind my immune system
fell apart and it was respiratory I
always got colds always shots you know
vaccines I knew the people by first name
at the hospital at Roosevelt Hospital in
New York I mean it was real with me when
I was sick something and I also have
asthma
did you really which went untreated like
I just said you have asthma still like
my mother said that's for [ __ ] don't
worry about it you don't need to have
asked me right now outgrew it my
daughter has it though really she has it
and now I see it in her and I got does
she have an inhaler yeah and you don't
use an inhaler at all anymore no did you
ever for like a week no my mother goes
to get rid of that you live in New York
City it's mackney Wow your mother's
heart so I grew up with this [ __ ]
thing and then when I was 16 I got put
the hustle for 13 days for a lung
infection from Paraguay service since
then like I'm not supposed to smoke hmm
I'm never supposed to smoke when I
started smoking I would get sick the
days afterward like I had a jump a
hurdle to smoke pot but when you were
smoking cigarettes what about that that
was a completa not even talk about that
but let's talk about the hurdles I had
smokin reefer early on I would smoke
reefer and it would be an event I would
have to take three or four days off it
would crush me for that long well then
once I built the Tower and saw that then
I started having to build the tolerance
of who I smoked dope with like if I
smoked dope with me you and Jamie and
somebody else the next day I'd have a
temperature do you get sick from someone
yeah 13 14 so by the age of 15 I already
knew how to keep my [ __ ] like if I
smoked with you and Jamie every day
that's who I smoked with once somebody
else comes into that circle I would get
sick hmm so I had to knock that out so I
had to be very aware at a young age who
I smoked with I got sick a lot when I
was competing I wasn't taking care of
myself back then I'd even take vitamins
I didn't take [ __ ] I got a second lot
because it was always stressed out too
cuz I was always nervous because
fighting all the time
so you know you get ready and the weeks
up to a tournament you know that's the
most stressful and the week of the
tournament I always come down with
something you know and you want a
fighting SEC fought SEC in Anaheim I
flew out to California to find the
Nationals I fought sick I had three
fight sick did we figure out what the
percentage that said that was an
estimation that was close to 60%
okay some obviously don't it wasn't like
20% those well I think as time goes on
we're getting a better picture of it
[Applause]